- I have a concern about critical theory.
This whole, everything
that's happening right now,
I believe it was a Trojan horse.
I believe that James Lindsay,
and how he described it as a Trojan horse,
he's exactly right on.
It's coming into our churches.
Dude, the division that it's
causing right now is insane,
because like you said,
it's another gospel.
It's another religion.
It's like, because once again,
they have their own epistemology.
So the way that they discover truth
is from a positional standpoint.
So how do I respond to that?
(serene music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and this
is the "Rubin Report."
Quick reminder, everybody,
to subscribe to our YouTube channel,
and click that pesky notification bell.
And joining me today is an
author, and a teaching pastor,
Nathan Finochio, welcome
to the "Rubin Report."
- Hey, it's good to be here, Dave.
- I am glad to have you, sir,
because as you probably know,
I do some talking to
people of faith, people,
that are skeptics, people
that are somewhere in between.
And I always find these to be sort of
the most interesting
conversations that I have.
So before we do anything
about what you're doing now,
tell me a little bit about
your journey to faith.
- Yeah, so I'm the son of a preacher man.
My dad has been in the ministry
as long as I could remember.
And I've sort of just fallen
into it, to be quite honest.
I tried to, kind of, not
necessarily run the other way,
but do something else, and
sorta just caught up to me,
it's like, so it just kind
of, this is what I do now.
'Cause it's just kind of what I know.
But I do,
I've always had a kind
of strong faith in God.
I just never saw myself
as the ministerial type,
because you know, like people of faith,
I guess spiritual leaders,
they kind of have a type.
in my opinion, they're kind of square,
and they stay home on Friday nights
and play Scrabble with grandma.
And it was just not what I
wanted to do with my life.
You know?
- Hey, don't knock Scrabble, man.
Everybody loves Scrabble.
- Look, I take that back, okay?
Scrabble is great, and
grandma's wonderful.
- Well, to your point though, you kinda,
it's like, well, wait a
minute, look at this guy.
He doesn't really look like a pastor.
And then on the other hand,
you look like sort of a modern Jesus.
So you're sort of doing a
little everything over there.
- It's, you know, it's a work in progress.
- (laughing) Did you, on the way,
you said you did a little something
before going into this,
even though you came
from a family of faith.
Was the faith part always there,
or did you mean that you
deviated from that too?
Or did you just mean that
sort of career wise or something else?
- I just meant that sort
of career wise, yeah.
I was doing music for about eight years.
And so yeah, kinda doing that,
and things just didn't work out
the way I kind of wanted them to work out.
I sort of went back to,
went back to the family farm, so to speak.
And so I'm just kind
of a doing ministry now
for the last gosh, I
dunno, last six years.
- So if somebody said
to you sort of lay out
what your belief system
is, what would that be?
Kinda broadly speaking.
- Yeah, so I'm a, I'm a
confessional Christian.
That's what I'd say.
I'm in the kind of the
brand of Christianity,
that I'm, or the stream that I flow in,
it's more of a Pentecostal
Christianity, you know?
So we're the ones that, I mean,
I've never handled a snake before,
but that's kind of what
Pentecostals are known for.
Tambourine destroying Pentecostals,
we're the ones that when
you go to our churches,
on the weekend, it's
kinda like a rock concert.
So we've got lasers and you know,
we kind of attract a younger crowd.
But our idea basically is that we have
a historic Orthodox
confessional Christian doctrine.
So we believe that the stuff
that the church has always believed,
and we confess and we profess that.
But we wrap it up in sort of
a modern, in a modern vibe.
- Yeah, do you get a
lot of pushback on that?
Sort of, I've seen this in
a few different versions,
where there's the sort of belief
that you just have to have the belief,
and the orthodoxy and the
conservative look at religion,
and then you bring in
music, you bring in lasers,
you bring in bands, and
all sorts of other stuff.
And people, a certain set of people
will think that that will kind of erode
the original message.
- Yeah, yeah, I think
that that's utter and
total ridiculousness.
Basically, I mean look at Vatican Three,
and kind of what the
Catholic church has done,
like is having services in English
somehow diminish the Catholic churches,
you know, their their message?
No, it doesn't.
So that's essentially what we're doing,
whereas they're just they're...
For them, progress is translating the mass
from Latin to English.
For us, we're, we're doing exactly that.
We're translating the message, but like,
the currency, I think of our generation
is music and the arts.
And so that's kind of how we
communicated that language.
- Right, so sort of speaking
to music and the arts,
what kind of put you on my radar
is that Justin Bieber is
a member of the church.
I don't want you to get into any specifics
about anyone that goes to the church,
but what do you sense is
happening with people of his age,
related to belief?
There does seem to be something going on,
you know, Kanye is running
these services now,
and as you just said,
it's sort of related to music and culture,
and something else.
It's not what we think
of when we just think of
like the traditional
religious perspective.
- Yeah, 100%, I think that people,
I know you mentioned Justin and Kanye,
as far as I know, they
had church upbringings.
So there's a lot of people
come up in the church.
I know Justin for a fact, did.
I went to, I spoke at his
home church in Canada.
I'm actually Canadian,
I've I grew up 45 minutes
from where he grew up.
So I know like, I mean,
Elvis, for crying out loud,
came up in the church.
It's not uncommon in the American story
that people in the arts come up in church,
and then they kind of
leave the small town,
and they go do big musical things.
So, but in terms of a return,
I mean, we saw it even in Elvis's career.
The only album that he
ever won a Grammy for
was for his gospel record.
So there's something, I
think, intrinsic to Americana,
and the church and music.
So it's a pretty common theme.
Why millennials and gen Z-ers
are reconnecting with the church,
or connecting for the first time to faith,
I think large in part due to the failure,
perhaps of secularism.
It doesn't work and
there's questions, I think,
that it's attempted to answer,
that it hasn't answered.
And that's why you'll even
see guys like Sam Harris,
who have become spiritual,
not in any sort of Orthodox sense,
but an awareness that maybe
there is something out there,
that we connect to, in
soul and spirit, et cetera.
So I think we have
something to offer people
that is reasonable, and
that is also experiential.
- So one of the things that
I've been talking about
on the show a lot lately,
is that I think a lot of
the problems we're having
is that we seem to be reaching
the end of secularism,
which I think is sort of
what you're alluding to,
that when you get to the
end of pure secularism,
with nothing else outside of itself,
that everything's on the table again.
And we don't know if men are
men, and women are women,
and we're debating, destroying our past
in the name of some utopian future,
and the rest of it.
Do you see that as just like
the natural kind of outgrowth
of what a purely secular society is?
- Yeah, I think, gosh,
without getting into
a huge history lesson,
what I would call,
I think there's two types of people
in our churches right now.
Okay, there's we might call leftists,
and a secular might be,
a secularist might be a better term.
But, and then we have,
for lack of a better term,
a conservative, which
I can't stand the term,
but just using generalizations.
And what I think has happened as a society
is that we have an epistemological crisis.
That's kind of what
happened, what has happened,
because secularism is
the idea, essentially,
that material is the only
thing that you can touch.
And we should all live together
in our material society.
And let's forget about
things that are non-material,
like spirituality, because those
things will just divide us.
And it kind of works out at first,
but then it begins to
hammer down everybody
into just material, and
people aren't just material.
And the world isn't just material.
There's a lot more to it than that.
And so we have this epistemology
that's kind of developed from secularism,
and that epistemology is essentially...
When we got rid of a
traditional authority,
which, traditional authorities like kings,
and the priests and church,
and not, they weren't
like doing bad things,
and that there was reason for them,
for us to be suspicious of it,
and so we did away with it.
It's sort of like now that we
have no traditional authority,
the self has become the
locus of everything.
Like we're the locus of interpretation.
And so there's a great deal of pressure
on people to know everything.
That's why, like, in our culture,
you have to self authenticate,
you have to self help.
You need to build up the self,
and you need to be the
best version of yourself,
because nobody out here is gonna help you,
and you can't trust anybody.
And so what happens is that experience
now becomes like, it
becomes the highest metric,
in a world where there's no
authorities that can be trusted.
And so in the church,
we have people that are coming in,
and it's all about experience.
And so that's, I think where,
to borrow from James Lindsay,
that's where a positional
epistemology becomes so massive.
We're dealing with it
with churches right now.
So it's like, people
love the idea of Jesus,
but the scriptures, to which,
so Christians, we appeal
to an external authority.
We believe things about reality,
that are just kind of,
they're incompatible
with most kids that are coming in.
Like kids that are coming in are going,
"Reality is my experience."
But Christianity is going,
"Reality is what God says
in the scriptures."
And so that's, it's kind of...
And it's very similar to,
that's why I think the Christianity
will save Western civilization,
because we might be the last ones
who believe in science,
which would be hilarious.
(laughing) But just the idea that,
we believe that that
truth exists externally.
Like imagine that religious fanatics
believe that truth
externally, Dave, right.
We believe in what we might call
phenomenological transcendence.
The idea that like a tree isn't,
you can't just call a tree
whatever you wanna call a tree.
You know, a tree is real.
And if you wanna go ahead
and drive your car into that tree,
you will experience
phenomenological transcendence.
You will agree with that.
But rather, why don't you live your life
like there are things
that exist outside of you,
and for us, the way that
we appeal to Christians,
we try to kind of try to
convert them to Christianity,
because Christianity is
this thing that's like,
it's reasonable, we believe
that truth is external.
It's not all about you,
and your experiences.
It's also about some things
that God has said in his Word.
And so morality isn't just kind of
whatever you want it to be,
or however you want to paint it.
It's God who created you,
he has some opinions,
he's God, it is what it is.
And so you need to, does that make sense?
So it's an epistemological
war that the church is in.
- Yeah, you gave me
about five roads there,
that we could shoot off of.
So I'm gonna try to come
around to all of them,
or get them into something.
- Let's do it all.
- But first.
- (laughing) I'll see if I can do it.
But first, you mentioned James Lindsay,
who I've had on the show, of course,
who wrote the book with Peter Boghossian,
about how to have important conversations.
One of the things that
I'm sort of amazed by,
by the sort of James
Lindsay, Peter Boghossian,
Michael Shermer, the more
I would say left leaning,
largely atheist crew
is that many of them are suddenly going,
"All those religious people
we were screaming about,
they're not so bad."
And they're appearing on
stage with religious people.
They're, I don't know if you know,
but just about six or eight months ago,
I was on stage in front
of 14,000 students,
at Liberty University,
with Jerry Falwell Jr. right next to me,
and it was just absolutely incredible.
And sure, we have some differences.
We have some theological differences.
We have some, you know,
spiritual differences,
and political differences,
but nobody cared.
Everybody was thrilled, it was wonderful.
But I'm curious what you think about that,
the fact that some of
the sort of main drivers
of secularism, are suddenly
looking at you guys,
basically and going,
"Huh, you're a lot nicer
than that other crew over there."
- Yeah, I don't think it's
just modern intersectionalism
that we're strange bedfellows.
I think that we have a
very similar epistemology,
and that's why we actually argue.
Dave, you can't argue with people
that you don't have the
same epistemology with.
We have the same epistemology as atheists.
Like we do have demands of literature,
and we come at things believing
that there are external forces.
Okay, the difference being
that an atheist would believe
in a strictly material universe.
But material, is super
important to Christians as well.
And the idea that truth lives externally,
is it's really important to us as well.
So I think that yeah, we find
ourselves on the same aisle
with respect to our epistemology,
and you know this about, I
mean, Christians aren't perfect.
And, you know, we've
slammed in our thousands,
and we've made some massive mistakes.
And one of my favorite quotes
of a Christian theologian,
is St. Augustine, who said that,
"The church is a whore,
but she's my mother."
We're aware, Dave, of the things
that have happened in
history that are stupid.
There's a lot of people
who've used the scripture
to do some really stupid things.
But yet we find ourselves now
debating with people who we
have the same epistemology.
I can't have a conversation with you,
if you can't define reality
the way that I define reality.
And so to me, once again, it's
an epistemological factor.
- Do you sense young people
that are showing up now,
sure, the lights and
the music is something,
and you're explaining sort
of the end of secularism,
so they feel that there's a hole there.
But do you sense just like
in the last couple years,
maybe because of the cultural war,
because of social media,
that the hole that they have
seems to be way bigger,
that it's maybe not just spiritual,
but it's also very community based.
You know, we got all of
these tools and apps.
and we thought it was gonna
make us more connected.
And in many ways, social
media made us antisocial,
and now people are
trying to find community
in oddly more traditional ways,
whether there's lasers or not.
- (laughing) Right.
Yeah, absolutely, I
remember there was a book
written in the '90s by a guy named Putnam,
the title was "Bowling Alone."
And it sort of was a sociological book,
just looking at the erosion
of community in America,
beginning with the bowling leagues.
It felt like bowling leagues where like,
they replaced church for my
grandfather's generation.
And now yeah, that's gone.
So there's definitely
a sociological factor.
I think that, to be quite honest with you,
the sociological factor may very well be
one of the biggest factors in the church.
We're all, we understand
the value of community.
We believe theologically that
we're not made to be alone.
There was one thing in
the garden that was wrong.
A lot of people think that, you
know, in that Genesis story,
that God creates this garden
and it's like, it's perfect,
it's paradise, well, it's not,
it was optimal for living.
And the one thing that was
wrong was that Adam was alone.
And so he creates Eve, and so
we're created for one another.
And we need one another desperately.
So that's definitely
a tenant of our faith.
And there's definitely a
sociological it factor to church.
And yeah, there's a giant...
I also believe that...
there's this book written
by a Pulitzer Prize winner.
I think his name is Ernest Becker,
and the title of it was
"The Denial of Death."
In his book, he's,
looking at secularism,
and kind of what it's done in modernity,
And he believes that
with the death of God,
society sort of was just
like, okay, well now I,
because I need somebody
to validate my reality,
to validate my existence,
to see me, because we need
to be seen as human beings.
And that's why we need relationship.
And so he believed that the first option
that modern stride was the love option,
in that, and that's why
everybody talks about
having the one, finding the one,
like 300 years ago, like
love wasn't the reason
why you got married.
But now we put all this emphasis,
and that's why we have
apocalyptic hookup culture,
you know, because we're
all trying to find God,
and for somebody to validate your living.
So to me, that's what the church does.
- Are you saying God's not on Tinder?
Is that what you're telling me?
- Oh, he's definitely
on Tinder (laughing).
He's definitely searching for people.
He's going after, he's left
the 99 and going after the one.
So I think that what you
said is absolutely right,
in a roundabout way, I think
that we're looking for love,
we're looking for romance.
And I think we've, in a strange way,
we do find it in community.
We find that validation that we need.
But in a more spiritual sense, Dave.
Yeah, we find it in God, in that he,
and that's what I believe,
and that's what we teach.
We teach that God's the one who sees you.
He's the one who goes after you.
You're not the one who
has been going after him,
but he's been the one
that's been pursuing you,
because he knows you, he
knows how to get to you,
and he loves you.
So when people sort of,
when that settles them,
there's a lot of things
in their life that change,
and being a part of a community
is definitely one of them.
- Yeah, so before you
mentioned the sort of lefty
verse conservative demographics
that you're dealing with in the church,
so as we've watched this
culture war just like explode,
all over the place, I know
that all sorts of churches,
temples, I have virtually
every organization,
secular or not, is dealing with
some sort of like internal split
over how to deal
with everything that's
happening these days,
literally from coronavirus
to Black Lives Matter,
and everything in between.
What version of that are
you seeing these days?
- Yeah, there's definitely a
political part of everything.
I mean, dude, this is insane.
Like it's insane, I keep
on telling my friends this.
I'm sure that all your
friends are just going,
"What is happening in 2020?"
There's a conversation in the
church right now, politically,
about the threshold of religious liberty,
versus government needing to keep tabs,
and a lid on coronavirus.
And so we're kind of, I guess,
exploring that threshold.
You got people who...
That absolutely falls along
ideological lines, right?
So it seems like there's
two types of Americans.
There's ones that want to,
they have a huge trust in the government.
My wife is one of 'em.
My wife is an Australian, I'm a Canadian,
but my wife is like, she
trusts the government.
She's just like, "They are, you know what,
they love us, and I want to
be," she told me last night,
she's like, "I wanna be nannied."
And I'm like, "My God, woman."
(laughing) I was just like,
"Have you read history?"
- Good luck with all of that.
- Totally, so you got my wife, Jasmine,
and then you've got me.
And I'm like the most
distrusting person of government,
because yeah, who are these angels?
You know, like the old argument,
who are these angels that are gonna make
all these right decisions for us?
So there's that's a huge
conversation of the church,
and that alone, Dave,
was tearing us apart.
Right, like so you got like pastors,
like calling other pastors,
or people calling up people,
like in the faith
community, just being like,
"You need to trust the government,
authority's from God."
And then now you have, of
course, George Floyd's death,
which was horrific, and tragic.
And you have Black Lives Matter,
the organization that's
kind of occupied some space
in wake of the George Floyd killing,
and then Ahmaud Arbery, because it looks,
from social media,
that young black men are
being hunted down and killed.
So yeah, you have this
major space and it's,
this is another thing that's
kind of dividing us right now.
It's just like the narrative to believe
and what we ought to do about it.
And regardless of if you
believe that narrative or not,
Christians are called to
mourn with those who mourn,
and weep with those who weep.
So finding that threshold of going, okay,
I might not agree with
the political narrative,
but I'm called to stand alongside
people who are in my life,
that regardless of whether or
not I believe that they are,
their emotions are rooted
in any kind of reality,
and I'm arguing from a,
if you're a conservative,
like I have a responsibility
towards them to love them.
You know, like my wife is
terrified of airplanes.
It's not rooted in
anything logical at all,
but I'm the one that's
stuck holding the bag,
and comforting her and getting her Xanax,
when we're on a flight.
And, you know, so there's
an element of that,
if you're a conservative,
that you have a responsibility
towards the people
that you're in community with,
that you're living life with,
and quoting stats at my wife
doesn't help her flight
anxiety (laughing).
- Right.
- So finding that threshold
- How worried are you?
- is the mess right now.
- Yeah, how worried are you though,
that letting in this sort of different,
what I would call a
religious belief system,
social justice, that once
it enters the institution,
enters the church, that in many ways
it will just, it will rot from the inside,
all of the good things that
you've been talking about.
I mean, this is what
we've sort of seen happen
to every secular institution.
It's happening to "The New York Times."
It's happening to "The Washington Post,"
it's happening to Harvard and Princeton,
and all of our liberal institutions.
So I'm sort of fascinated where,
with this idea that it could be entering,
sort of conservative or
religious institutions,
and that they may not even have
the correct defense
mechanisms to purge it,
or keep it at bay.
- That's exactly what's happening.
So it's not necessarily, so for me,
I've tried to dance this line where like,
the idea of Black Lives Matter is like,
it's an idea, it's a saying.
I've sort of divorced it
from the organization.
They don't like that,
but I've divorced it from the organization
because, you know, yeah,
Black lives do matter.
And so if there are instances
of where there's police brutality,
that doesn't seem to fit the rest,
I mean, you know, as we examine the data,
that's one of the big ones.
We know that the Harvard Rolands,
his paper, and we know like
the study that was done,
Heather McDonald obviously
lays this all out.
But one of the things that I
have a giant question mark over
is the police brutality part.
I don't know if we're nailing that well.
And so let's say that you're
like me, where you're going,
"Okay, the shooting part,
there's no racial bias
That's been detected by
three major studies."
But police brutality, do
have a question on that,
like why are 30% of Blacks being accused
of resisting arrest?
Are they resisting, is
that what's happening,
or are the police being antagonistic
towards 'em or whatever.
So let's just say for example,
that there is some antagonism,
it needs to be dialed back.
So I stand with my brother who feels,
he's terrified, okay.
And he's like, "Nate, you know,
like I just feel like Black Lives Matter."
"Okay, man, Black Lives Matter.
Okay, I'm with ya Black
Lives," like I'll say that.
Now the organization,
they believe in the
denuclearization of the family,
which is doing nobody a service,
particularly the Black
community in America, right?
So for me, obviously I have
some fatter theological concerns to fry,
but I'm walking this line
where I'm in community
with my Black brothers and sisters.
And so for me, like once again,
I have a concern about critical theory.
Everything that's happening right now,
I believe it was a Trojan horse.
I believe that that James Lindsay,
and how he described it as a Trojan horse,
he's exactly right on, it's
coming into our churches.
Dude, the division that it's
causing right now is insane,
because like you said,
it's another gospel.
It's another religion.
It's like, because once again,
they have their own epistemology.
So the way that they discover truth
is from a positional standpoint.
So how do I respond to that?
It's almost an impossible dance,
but I have to show rational
compassion, not empathy,
because empathy is, as we've seen,
in the last, like 10,
15 years in psychology.
is dangerous, and your
biases come into empathy.
I have to have what's
called rational compassion.
So I have to reasonably
move through the data,
move through the things
that are happening,
using my Christian
worldview and framework,
and my epistemology.
And then as I'm checking
these movements and going,
"Okay, these are their demands, right?"
'Cause everything has a demand.
We demand that you overhaul,
James say you can't tear down
the master's house with
the master's tools.
So we have to completely
change how we structure,
not just the way we structure
our church organization,
but we also demand that like the way
that you go about finding
truth changes as well.
And so at that point, for me,
I'm not gonna fight peripherals.
Like, in any good argument,
you always argue first principles.
You don't argue peripherals.
And so for me, when it comes to
the Black Lives Matter movement,
when it comes to things that
are happening on the streets,
and the protests, et cetera,
I'm not gonna, there are some things
I think that are peripheral.
And as conservatives, we get
a little bit sidetracked by.
And so to me, the critical theory thing,
and this is why I think James Lindsay
is just so on the money right now,
is because it's the, you
don't go after the fruit,
you go after the root.
And to me, critical theory is the root
of this giant problem.
It's the reason why that
the political narrative
has been spun the way it is.
And so to me, that's what I'm going after,
while holding the hand of
people that are hurting.
- Yeah. I mean, it's
almost an impossible place
to put yourself because you're
trying to hold something,
you're trying to be open.
You're trying to retain ideas
and also not put people down, it's tough.
What do you make of this idea,
so you hit on that critical theory,
whatever, cultural Marxism,
whatever you wanna call this thing,
that it's religious in nature.
One of the facets that
I'm constantly amazed by
is there's no forgiveness in this thing,
that basically, if you're
white or you're cisgendered,
or you're Christian or whatever,
you're privileged and thus bad,
and that really, you
just have to pay penance
your whole life, you have
to live on your knees,
your whole life.
Where most religions have some
level of forgiveness, right.
You can actually atone for your sins,
and hopefully be a better
person on the other side.
This thing doesn't have that.
This thing has, oh well,
live like a slave forever, in effect.
- Right, 100%, so in critical theory,
you're sort of guilty
before proven innocent.
So everybody's guilty.
And as James Lindsay has
observed in his findings,
all of the critical
theorists believe essentially
that if you will even,
even for example, if I wanna be,
somebody accused me of
problematic allyship yesterday.
But that's the whole point,
the whole point is that I can never be
truly an ally.
My allyship is always
gonna be problematic.
There's like, so there's no,
there's no end to it.
It just continues to be what it is.
So, yeah, they don't forgive,
because there's nothing to forgive,
because I'm stuck in the oppressor group.
If I'm stuck in the oppressor group,
and there's no escaping it,
there can be no forgiveness if
there's no repentance, right?
Like, isn't that how it works?
So that I'm just perpetually a sinner,
and I'm just going to continue
to perpetuate the oppressor group.
And there's nothing that I can do.
Yeah, so that's why, of course,
cancel culture is actually
the logical conclusion
of critical theory, right?
It's the logical conclusion,
that to be consistent logically,
they have to be consistent
in their cancel culture,
because they have to get
rid of the oppressor class.
- I hate to tell you,
I think it's beheadings
is the logical conclusion.
Cancel culture is just,
cancel culture is just a stop on the way,
but we can sort of leave that.
Just for you personally,
dealing with this,
the idea that everything's
become political,
and in many ways, I think people used to
go to have religious experiences,
regardless of the religion,
they would go there to escape politics,
that that religion sort of offered them
that separation from the real world,
to think of something
timeless, something like that.
To see it all seep in,
just for you as a leader of a community,
How's that been on you?
- Yeah, so one of the things that I do,
in my role, is I travel
to a number of churches.
I'm not the lead pastor in a community,
but I go to all of the
different communities,
and I speak at a number of churches.
And so what is it like?
Well, yeah, people are, people don't,
church is supposed to be
a place where they hear
about the love of God for them.
And they hear about the sacrifice,
and they remember the
Lord's passion, et cetera.
And so it's kind of become,
in some circles, in some churches,
the gospel has totally
become about current events.
And I think that that's
definitely problematic.
It definitely become problematic where,
in Christianity we teach, essentially,
that everybody's a priest.
In fact, the Protestant
reformation happened
because one of Martin Luther's 95 problems
with the Catholic church was
that you had to have a priest
to connect with God.
And the New Testament is
replete with scriptures,
about the priesthood of the believer.
And so what this necessarily
means for Protestants like me,
is that every believer is
supposedly coming to church,
to be a priest, that's
what you literally do.
So you come to what a priest do,
They minister to the Lord,
and they minister to others.
But like when you come to church,
and it's a lesson on critical theory,
you know, and there's
like, there's no escape.
I think that people aren't
able to do their job,
as a Christian.
I think that it's really
tough to glorify God,
and to worship God when it's like,
you're in a perpetual classroom,
And there's just doubt
and there's confusion.
And I think that one of my
biggest frustrations for me
is that I don't think that
a lot of church leaders
have their pulse on this
epistemological issue.
So it's washing,
like pastors are good
people and they love people.
And so from that good place
of going, "I love people,"
they're probably going, "we
need to talk about this,
because this is a real,
this is, this is where
the rubber hits the road."
But problematically, if you're not,
you don't have your pulse on culture,
and understanding the
undercurrents epistemologically,
you know, you're creating a
lot of confusion for people.
So that's absolutely what's happening.
- Do you think certain
religious denominations
and certain sex within religions,
are just better at keeping
some of this stuff at bay?
So it seems to me it's not perfect,
but like something like
Orthodox Jews, let's say,
have really kept this at bay in a way
that conservative or reformed
Jews haven't been able to.
Or evangelicals, I think,
have done a pretty good job
at keeping it at bay.
Do you think that there
are like certain strengths
and weaknesses from a
Protestant perspective,
or another denomination perspective,
that makes certain
worldviews a little more able
to stand up to these things?
- Absolutely, so it's a focus,
it's a focus on their purpose.
Like, why do Orthodox Jews exist, right?
Like they know why.
And I mean, look,
break down sometimes to
the way that they dress,
like they're in this world,
but they're not of this world,
sort of as Jesus said.
And so I think that they
do a really great job,
you know, of like focusing
on their community,
and focusing on the
reasons why they exist.
So there is a definitely a balance to be,
see what I look at Jesus, and once again,
this is a epistemological issue.
But when I look at Jesus,
I don't look at somebody
who is necessarily engaged
in the politics of his day.
I think that Jesus said,
"My kingdom's not of this world."
And so he had a little bit of,
I'm in the world, but I'm not of it.
Does that mean that we don't
engage in issues of justice?
No, it doesn't mean that we don't.
I think that marching
with Martin Luther King
was the right thing to do,
during the civil rights.
And I think that defeating Hitler
was probably a good thing to do.
I think that the church
doesn't run from things,
but it's finding,
it's sifting through the things
that we should engage in.
How we should engage, and
the threshold of that,
and it's a conversation
that we're having right now.
And yeah, evangelicals probably have done
a really great job because evangelicals
are a bit more heady.
Pentecostals are probably a bit more,
we lean a bit more experiential.
I wish that Pentecostals were a bit more
like Evangelicals, in that they sifted,
they had their, like Albert Mohler,
he's the president of the
Southern Baptist Convention.
And he sent out a letter
on critical theory,
to all of the pastors,
and look, "Hey guys,
this is what's happening."
Like the Pentecostals
is a bit of the wild wild
west, in Christianity.
I don't know if you knew this,
but we've only been around for 120 years,
and there's 750 million of us.
And we're the fastest growing
version of Christianity,
in the world, like we're gonna eclipse,
we're gonna eclipse
Catholicism in 50 years.
So our brand of Christianity,
in terms of filling stadiums,
and people singing our
songs and all that stuff,
it's a big place, and it's like,
it is the battleground
for Christian expression.
And that finding that threshold
of where politics are,
and what Christianity is
gonna look like, et cetera.
So Pentecostals don't, we don't have,
we don't have like a grand poobah,
like an Albert Mohler,
or like a Jerry Falwell,
or whatever, who kind of dictates to us
or will tell us, "Hey guys,
this is what's coming,"
We're very much independent.
So because of that,
because the nature of that,
and because we're so experiential,
and because we're so kind
of up on the culture,
it's a mess right now.
But nobody knows what to believe,
but we know that people are hurting.
And so we're gonna run towards people,
because we're experiential,
and people are having these experiences.
So we're gonna love them.
But for the rational
part of our compassion
seems to be a bit missing.
And we're unaware as to what
is really inside this Trojan horse.
- Yeah, well that's why exactly why
I wanted to have this conversation.
'Cause I just see this
happening across the board.
And I'm fascinated when I see it
in communities that I'm
not necessarily part of.
It's incredible, so when you see things,
like you're in California too,
our wonderful, progressive
governor, Gavin Newsom,
basically telling people that
they can't sing in church,
'cause that can spread COVID,
and then, our mayor here in L.A.,
Garcetti is out there with no mask on,
kneeling in front of protestors.
And then also tells us
we can't have 4th of July celebrations,
or, you know, we gotta stay in our house.
All of these just crazed
conflicting messages.
Do you think that also is
just a driver for religion?
Like it seems like they're
specifically attacking religion
at some level, right?
You see de Blasio locking up playgrounds,
for Orthodox Jews kids to go to,
but then he's out there in
the streets with protesters,
that there seems to be like
an actual assault on religion.
And then at the same time,
it's like everything they
send us is mixed messages.
So it's like, ah, maybe
that's a little paranoid.
- Yeah, no, I think that you're right.
And to be honest with you,
I feel like it's been open season on Jews,
for some time now.
And I think that that's definitely,
that that falls along a
particular political aisle,
whether we care to admit it or not.
With respect to Christians,
and houses of worship,
yeah, like Americans believe
in peaceful assembly,
and the right to assemble and
you know, freedom of religion.
And so there's, once again, you know,
there's exploring that threshold
of who you can tell to gather.
You know, for example,
like a popular pastor
down here in California,
Jentezen Franklin, made
a statement about this,
on his social media, three days ago.
And all hell broke loose
in Pentecostal Christendom.
And Jentezen was just like,
"Hey, like I feel like
this is a bit arbitrary,"
and but telling churches that we can't,
but Jentezen marched with the protestors.
And he goes, "Look, I marched,
so I, you know, I was there."
And what I'm saying though,
is I think it's arbitrary
to allow people to protest,
and not allow people to sing in church.
And it's just, it's like--
- That seems rational to
me, that seems sensible.
But you're saying not
everyone operates in sense.
- Right, and people screaming, right?
Like, so like if you can scream in a mask,
right beside somebody,
or you can sing in a mask.
People are going, "It's about droplets."
Yeah, 100%, but that's
what people are doing,
people are screaming.
So it's like, so I just think that like
the concern about COVID-19,
in some ways is like a little bit,
it's miss (laughing),
I have so many friends
who've had COVID-19 right?
Like you have a 98.8% chance
of surviving this thing,
if you're under the age of 40.
Okay, so like, but it's all,
it all seems to be young people,
young progressives, who
are screaming at Jentezen,
young Christian progressive's going,
"How dare you bring the
protesters into this?"
He's, "I'm not, I marched,
but don't you see this a bit arbitrary?"
And then he said, "Make sure
that you vote your faith this fall."
And that was the straw that
broke the camel's back.
So it was just like, are
you telling us to vote now,
and who to vote for?
And I don't know, dude, it's a mess.
And, but I think that once again,
I think it doesn't fall along
necessarily faith lines,
but it would fall along ideological lines,
in terms of what type of
government do you want?
Do you want a government
that is overreaching?
Or do you want a government
who is going to just allow
churches, and allow people,
to do what they wanna do?
And you know, I mean,
as far as I know, Dave,
hasn't it been that
every single high court
has ruled that these governors'
overreach of churches
has been unconstitutional,
is that correct?
- I don't know if it's every single one,
but I've seen several of 'em, yeah.
They're, I mean, they should,
look, we have a fourth amendment,
we have the right to assemble.
So the idea that Newsom's saying,
"You can't do it in church,
but you can do it on the streets,"
it's simply not constitutional.
- Yeah, so I think that this type of stuff
will galvanize a particular
brand of Christians.
But once again, in Pentecostalism,
you know, our epistemology
has already kind of been
experiential and positional.
Our church definitely is
split right down the line,
in terms of how people will vote,
how people see like, like my wife.
My wife wants to be nannied.
God bless her.
I don't (laughing).
So you see that we have some serious,
I'm married to her, okay.
So like we have some serious,
we have some fat fish to fry.
- All right, then I only
got one more for you,
because we've talked
about sort of the strife,
and everything that's got us
here, and everything else.
But as a man of faith, in
a crazy time that we're in,
gimme something hopeful, if you got it.
What, sort of an outlook
that gets us past this,
and how do we get to something
that will start feeling a little more,
maybe, well, maybe feeling
isn't the right word,
that will create a reality,
that will be a little more in
line with some of the things
that we've talked about here,
that are the good things.
- Yeah, so I think that there are only,
us Christians believe that
Jesus is gonna come back,
and he is going to rule and
reign on the earth forever.
That's that's what we believe.
So until that happens,
I think that there's gonna
continue to be chaos.
Now, God has given us,
we believe in this doctrine
called common grace,
where we believe that God has
given men faculty and reason.
And I believe that one of the ways
that we can limit the effects of the fall,
and the effects of sin,
and the effects of brokenness,
is by limiting government.
So yeah, like what is the hope for things
to maybe get better?
Ultimately, the return
of Christ and the gospel,
you know, that God will heal the world.
And when he heals the world,
then he becomes president,
there's no more elections.
His government will be so good,
that it'll be caused for praise eternally.
Until that happens, I think
that limiting people's ability
is probably our greatest hope.
So, yeah, I don't think
that the scriptures necessarily paint
some sort of utopian, you know,
let's bring the kingdom
down to earth right now,
before Jesus comes back,
and the scriptures aren't
redemptive, necessarily, that way,
in terms of things are gonna get better.
Things probably will get worse.
Just knowing humanity,
humanity needs a Savior.
The world is broken.
And I think that we can
all agree about that,
but I don't think the fix is more people.
The fix is Jesus Christ,
he always has been.
And I think that when he comes back,
and he's King, we'll be okay.
And I think that that's
actually great hope.
Like here's some hope,
put your hope in Jesus.
Put your hope in somebody who's
rulership, and his kingdom,
will be good for everybody.
So that's my two thoughts.
- All right, you took us on some hope.
Now in good conscience,
I can't send people to Twitter,
after a conversation like this.
Where can people go to find out
a little bit more about
you and what you do?
- They can go to my
Instagram, Nathan Finochio,
and or my website, nathanfinochio.ca,
'cause I'm a Canadian.
And you know, they can hate on me,
and if they have any issues,
if they have any problems
with this program,
just send an email to daverubin@gmail.com.
- (laughing) I don't
have that Gmail, so yes,
they can send it there.
All right, Nathan, it's been
a pleasure talking to you,
and hopefully when all
this stuff clears up,
we'll be able to do
this in person sometime.
- It was a pleasure, Dave, thank you.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our spirituality playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.